it has been an unprecedented year in
politics leading up to Tuesday's midterm
elections we've seen an historic number
of women and minorities running for
office and something else is new
until recently scientists have steered
clear of the political fray but this
year over 450 candidates with STEM
backgrounds that science technology
engineering and math are seeking state
and federal offices Alex Wagner has more
on why 2018 may be the year of the
scientists I believe that if we're gonna
be take a real approach at fixing our
healthcare system and transforming our
healthcare system we need to have a
nurse at the table Lauren Underwood a
nurse from Chicago I think that what you
have right now is a perceived threat to
just the basic concept of science and
facts and Joseph cops are an aerospace
engineer from Texas are just two of the
hundreds of scientists throwing their
lab coats into the political ring for
the first time is it hard to make the
jump from those sort of more analytic
fields to politics I don't think so and
here's why the whole reason why I got
into aerospace engineering as a cadet at
West Point why I wanted to be an
astronaut was because I was inspired as
a kid there was nothing more American
than the moon landings so in terms of
public service it's just a natural
extension so the scientific method
allows you to make hypotheses and then
where we can leverage ideas we can test
ideas we can see what works and that is
what I intend to do cops are served in
the Army for 20 years ran his own
company and decided this year was the
year to run for Congress in May cops are
one his primary in Texas is 21st
district there is a theory out there
that scientists are kind of wonky
they're kind of Lab Rats they're not
people persons right you don't seem to
fit that mold no I am a boot blue-jean
beer-drinking kind of an engineer are
there more like you of course there are
so that's the best part about
stereotypes if you lead with walking
into a discussion I'm an aerospace
engineer I'm here to solve the problem
it's not gonna solve anybody's problem
but if you walk in and say I too
struggle with this or I to understand
that
and then start to have it kind of come
out that's my favorite part of any
conversation when someone would look at
me and say well how'd you figure that
out he's some kind of rocket scientist
you're like Underwood at 26 years old
hopes to be the first african-american
woman to represent
Illinois's 14th congressional district
this is a district that is gone
Republican the last several election
cycles you are someone that comes from a
non-traditional political background do
you feel like this is an uphill battle
no I feel like this is what this moment
is calling for we have witnessed
something that I feel like never
happened before we see our policymakers
trying to dismiss facts and they are
ignoring facts and not consulting
experts but the end of the day truth
penetrates we need people with diverse
backgrounds the decision-making table
and two former EPA chiefs christine Todd
Whitman and Gina McCarthy say that
although the majority of scientists are
running as Democrats the need for
scientists at the table isn't red or
blue personally are they left or right
yeah of course everyone has their own
political opinion but when they are
doing their science advisory board
that's peer reviewed they care about
their reputations they are not going to
jeopardize them by fiddling with a
science Whitman a Republican served
under President George W Bush and
McCarthy a Democrat served under
President Obama they both believe
scientists voices are needed
particularly now what do you make of the
fact that 400 scientists are running for
office in the 2018 elections I think you
know it there's clearly they see the
same thing that we do which is it's not
just the science under attack but it's
the scientists themselves and we need
people in leadership positions in the in
the public sector who can helped make
sure there's evidence and fact-based
decisions being made not everyone agrees
do you still think that climate change
is a hoax look I think something's
happening something's changing and it'll
change back
again in a recent interview with 60
minutes President Trump repeated his
skepticism about climate change and
question the motives of scientists in
general so you just also have a
political agenda the war on science
didn't start with the Trump
administration but it has gone from what
felt like a war on science to an all-out
war on facts and that has acted as a
catalyst hello Shaughnessy Norton is the
president of three one for action a
non-profit political action committee
helping stem candidates learn the
political ropes this year they received
interest from over 7,500 scientists
whether it's cybersecurity or nuclear
weapons protecting the integrity of our
elections or or something like climate
change why wouldn't we want scientists
at the table helping to decide policy
and as deciders and not just as advisers
but there's risk in this approach
overwhelmingly I think seventy-five
percent of the country has a positive
view of scientists being trustworthy are
you concerned at all that that number
diminishes once there is the
introduction of politics specifically in
the realm I know I wouldn't be dead I
wouldn't be worried about it because
scientists are coming into the political
realm are standing for office we need
more scientists we need STEM education
and we need more people taking it up of
all from all walks of life scientists
are not interested in becoming political
leaders so that they can politicize the
science they want to join so that the
science can not be politicized Alex
Wagner CBS News very encouraging that so
many scientists are in the races this
year yeah a great last point there it's
not about politicizing it it's to avoid
politicizing these yeah science has
gotten us far in this country and around
the world
sure has